I wonder if we could start this
conversation with you laying out whether
you think you need to change course in
2024 and what your political and
Military goals are for next year we have
one strategy goal to De occupied our
territories to be on the borders of our
country our goals didn't change the goal
is to save and to have more successful
steps in the black
to continue success on Crimea on the
south I can't tell you the details but
we will do it and to defend East to save
har to save these very important cities
of Ukraine the war the
2024 this is the new page this is the
war not in
Ukraine because
informationally the challenges in the
Middle East
the training mission of Hamas that that
pushing Arab world the chaos in African
continent we are the part of all this
war Europe don't speak about support to
Ukraine you support
you yourself giving us money or giving
us weapon you support yourself
ukrainians are fighting for the world
that is the answer what the world has to
focus and
recognize many people outside Ukraine
are saying maybe it is time to negotiate
with Putin maybe it is time to start
talking can you tell me categorically
whether that is an option for you in
2024 or not that is not the the moment
of of
discussion of uh compromises or not
compromises because we don't have any
fundamental
steps forward to the peace from Russia
we have to speak with Russian not attack
us anytime Russia can attack you you
have to be ready why I have such
reaction because all their steps mean
another thing when they have discussion
on conference of of Putin he said no we
didn't get all the results we will go
forward what does it mean that we have
to sit and say sorry please stop or
something like this it's not our
position this weakness and he feel it
like like animal because he is animal
and like filling of the blood and that's
why he will feel his strongness and he
will eat you totally with all your EU
Nat Freedom democracy forget about it
that's why I don't see any
any
signals about peace I see only steps of
terroristic
con